as the United States currently descend
into a whirlwind of protests and riots
and chaos I thought it might be
important to look at the symbolism of
protest the symbolism of riots what they
can mean what is their structure now I
want to warn you that this video is not
going to be political so for those
hoping to see me virtue signal or
comment or make some kind take some kind
of political stand you're not going to
see this here but if you're interested
in understanding the mechanisms both
positive and negative of protests then
this might be the video for you
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so in order to understand protests we
have to understand first of all and
accept the basic idea that societies lay
themselves out as hierarchies and so
within these hierarchies there are
elements which are above and our
authorities have a responsibility to
care to protect the people below also
responsibility to protect them from each
other to maintain order as well and you
also have people who would be in that
higher power hierarchy are lower and are
usually there to follow the rules to
obey the rule of law to obey the way
that this order comes down upon them and
to benefit from it of course they also
have to benefit from this rule because
it is the manner in which society is
held together and we avoid chaos we
avoid people coming into our homes and
robbing all of this is the first
prerequisite in understanding what
protest is and so protest always comes
from below protest always comes from the
people it's the people who are
complaining about the manner in which
the authority is laid out the manner in
which the authority is manifesting
itself it could be a complaining on a
scale which can go from complaining
about specific rules which are seem
unfair complaining about how the rules
do not afford you enough it can also be
a deeper complaining which is a
complaining about the authority itself a
desire to remove to replace the
authority right there because we think
it is inadequate and it can go all the
way to anarchy and to anarchism in
believing that the authority itself as a
concept has to be removed and so we have
to understand that when we're looking at
a protest or when we're seeing
protesting activities when you're what's
going to happen is within the act of
protest you're often going to see every
level of
scale playing out at once you will see
within the act of protesting those who
are protesting more narrowly a certain
event a certain thing which they think
is unfair they will be protesting the
Authority itself as the particular
Authority for being unacceptable all the
way down to the desire to dismantle the
entire system and a desire to dismantle
all systems basically is the most
extreme version of that so if we look at
what's going on today we can see that
all of this is going on and so depending
on how you want to play the narrative
you can focus on one or the other of
these and that's important to understand
if you want to be fair about any
situation you can focus on those who are
protesting a specific thing peacefully
and doing the thing if you want to say
that the protests are legitimate and
then you can also focus on those that
are creating the anarchy and looting and
destroying if you want to show that the
protesting is illegitimate you know and
both of those narratives are possible
because they're all happening at the
same time it just depends on where you
you point your attention and to simply
call the other narrative a legitimate is
not going to work in a discussion
because the other narrative is
legitimate as well those two things are
how all these things are happening
simultaneously in a protest and so in
order to understand the structure of
protest
the best way to understand it is to
understand it analogically to understand
it in your body
in your person to understand it on
smaller scales like families and then it
can help us see how this structure is
playing itself out so you have to you
have to see that the top of a hierarchy
so whether it be your mind your thought
your you know your identity whether it
be the family the parents that are above
in the family whether it be in the
society that you have the authorities
above any other people below there's an
exchange which happens between the two
and so the
the the people from above will give down
and the people from below will support
right they'll act as it is it kind of
support for that for the Authority which
is above a way for the authority to show
itself and for the people below then
what you see is the authority acts as a
binding agent which helps us remain
together which helps us to be one to be
a nation to be a city to be a family and
to be a person right and so this
exchange is the normal way to go until
the the protest happens when the bottom
part feels like there is a disconnect
between the two when the bottom part
feels like that which is above is not
acting properly is not acting according
to the interests of that which is below
and so you can imagine the for the
easiest way to understand protesting is
to understand it really as a child and
you have you so you have a parent and
you have a baby and the baby when the
baby is hungry the baby will protest the
baby will cry in order for you to feed
the baby and so that is the most
immediate you know aspect of protesting
another way to understand it is for
example hunger you are hungry your your
stomach is grumbling and your stomach is
is protesting the fact that you haven't
given it anything so you are sitting
you're working you are one you want to
focus on the on the task that you're
doing but your stomach is saying pay
attention to me my friend you can't
ignore me I'm here I need to be fed and
I'm and I am what is supporting you so
if you don't feed me at some point my
protestation is going to disable the
very functioning of the body and it's
the same with a child if you have a
child that is asking for something a
child that that wants to be fed if you
do not feed the child the child will
scream and scream and scream until
everything is impossible until all your
family activities cannot function the
family will break down if there isn't
this a 10
from to what is below it so would you
and you have to understand it also as as
a hierarchy that is that we have at all
these different levels we have the same
same situation where you as being below
it's calling upon that which is above to
make sure that you're taken care of but
that at that level that's also happening
above you can imagine that in business
for example where the employees need
something they need some tools or they
need some resources in order to do the
work and or they're not getting paid
enough and so they're stressed and
they're they're struggling to take care
of their daily life and so they asked
for from to their bosses they asked for
more resources to do their work or for
their lives and then the boss has those
bosses have to answer but then the same
thing will then happen above and so the
level of bosses above they also maybe
want to raise they maybe want more
possibility for the factory or for
whatever it is that they're doing and so
then they have to ask above in order to
receive the authority from above and
this in in a business you have this
hierarchy where this will happen in
every level and so you can see in in
scripture for example in the Proverbs
there's a wonderful verse which says
whoever closes his ear to the cry of the
poor will call out and not be answered
so you can understand that in Scripture
really it is this idea of the poor and
so the poor have nothing they have to
receive what they have from above and so
they they moan they grumble they
complain they ask to be taken care of
and if you do not listen to the cries of
that which is below you will also not be
answered from above so it it works in
the hierarchy where you have to take
care of the needs of that which is below
if you don't then you will not receive
from that which is above and you can
understand that as just a moral
statement but you can also understand it
also in terms of very practical means
think again about the company where you
have let's say employees that are asking
for something for tools to do their work
or they are not paid enough for theirs
ugly and so they're distracted they're
not focused on what they're doing and
then they asked their boss for more
possibility more flexibility or whatever
now if the boss doesn't doesn't give
them what they need to the capacity that
he's capable of in order to increase
their possibility of producing then when
that boss is going to ask above for more
there's a chance that the people above
are going to look around and say well
you know why would we give you what have
you proved you haven't proven to us
anything and so they might look to
another department or to someone else in
order to give allocate the resources so
you have to take care of those below you
so that those above you will see you and
see your grumbling as also legitimate so
that they will also want to also want to
answer that okay and so you can see in
Scripture there the best place where you
can see the question of protesting or
complaining or grumbling is in the story
of the exodus so when the Israelites
leave Egypt they go out into the desert
and so they have their there out into
the deserts they have nothing and they
complain and what's important to
understand is that at first when they
complain their complaints are legitimate
in Scripture there's a sense in which
there's God and Moses are a little bit
annoyed at the complaint and that's
almost like it's inevitable you know
when your cry child is crying it's
annoying you can't help but be a little
bit annoyed when the people below you
are complaining but there's also a
manner in which God will then answer
that complaint so the complaint has to
come first you can the poor ask the and
and you can understand that also in
terms of just us in terms of prayer as
well that's related to this so we asked
we grumble we we show our we show that
we're struggling right we show it to
that which is above us and so the the
Israelites as they're in the desert they
encounter these salty waters so their
waters that they can't use bitter waters
they're really the waters of chaos and
so
they grumble they complain they like we
need water right we need one and then
God gives them water then they complain
that they're hungry and then God gives
them manna and and there's another place
again where they complained that they
need water that thirsty and then then
God makes water flow out of the rock and
so you can see that the the grumbling
comes first and the protest it's related
also to the problem of the question and
I've talked about this before the idea
of the how the question comes before the
answer the desire comes before the name
or before the the possibility comes
before the answer and so an example that
I use all the time but it fits a little
bit in this question is when the mother
of God when Mary goes to Christ and she
tells him that there's no wine left
right she is there's a there's a request
there's an asking and the grumbling is
really a type of asking but of course it
because it's the lower parts of you
because it's the lower parts of you it
manifests itself not as a not as a
asking in a logical way but just as a a
kind of grumbling of discontent so
really the stomach or the child crying
is the best way to understand that that
just expression of need and of lack of
lack of something right so that's why
the analogy between the family the child
is the best analogy to to get but then
the thing is with these protests are the
idea of protesting is that just like
your body just like your child you have
to find a balance between let's say the
compassion and the order and that
balance is extremely difficult to find I
don't pretend to know what the balance
is but there is to an extent to which
the desire the needs of the poor have to
be met have to be answered by that which
is above and the the idea that your
stomach you also have to answer the
needs of your stomach you need to answer
its grumbling the same with your child
you need to answer that you need to
answer the needs of your
but then that balance can also tip in
the other way because the problem with
your belly is that it's never satisfied
right the problem with a child is also
that a child is never satisfied and so
if you give in to all the DS all the
grumbling of your child and if you give
in to all the grumblings of your belly
well for your belly you will become fat
you'll become diabetic you'll become
unhealthy and your child will become a
spoiled brat and we often think that
protests only happens to the very very
desperate but that is actually not true
and your experience of your own body and
your experience of your family you will
realize that that's not true
so protests happen in every level they
happen in the most desperate and in the
Bible it is said that you need to answer
that protest which comes from from
poverty you would say but there's also a
protest which comes from a kind of
spoiled attitude an attitude that I am
owed things and so your belly is if you
don't really not careful your belly is
always hungry your belly your desires
will always be cycling back in you'll
always have more and then you can get
the image you know that kind of
narrative in this situation of the the
workers who demand from their bosses and
demand and demand and demand to a point
where at some at some point the boss
will take the factory and move it to
China or take the factory move it to
South America or whatever because the
demands of the body are so big that they
don't fit the capacity of the head to
provide for it and to answer those
demands it's just there is no it's
impossible for the system to handle so
much demand and so then the system will
break down you see the same of course
with children with children that will
you know throw tantrums to get them the
tiniest thing
their tiniest little difficulty answered
they're there you know whatever little
toy they want or game or what or just to
get whatever they want or to go to bed
later or to eat ice cream for dinner or
whatever the child if you always give in
to the grumbling then the child will
become a spoiled brat that will expect
more and more and sadly the thing is
this is also true in society and so as
society actually gets richer and as
let's say all of our society moves up in
terms of absolute poverty you know there
is no absolute poverty at least so
little absolute poverty in North America
it's almost it's almost zero compared to
just a hundred or two hundred years ago
as people have more that doesn't mean
that they will stop protesting it means
that at every level there is the
possibility of expressing the lack
because there is a sense also that
because things come from above those
that are above you you know you you can
start to think like that has to come
down it has to has to lower and so then
there has to find there has to be this
balance between the grumbling and the
authority so you can see in Scripture
this is what happens in the story of
Exodus the Israelites ask for water God
gives it to them the Israelites ask for
food God gives it to them and then there
is the moment in the story where God
kind of there's an in-between right
where God gives a mix of rigor and mercy
he gives he gives in to the to the
desire but also says you got to stop
this is it like this is the limit you
need to stop so this happens when the
Israelites asked for meat so the
Israelites are receiving this mana from
heaven they're receiving the water and
then the Israelites will actually it's
important to notice in the text that it
says the mixed multitude so you have
this mixture of Israelites and other
peoples that are there in the group and
this mixture is one of the cause
is of the now the grumbling to get
bigger because when you have mixture
when you don't have a clear let's say
United group then the mixed elements
don't feel as much the need to submit to
the authority they just don't because
it's not their thing they they are they
feel marginally connected to the thing
and so it's normal that that's where the
the grumbling can continue once the
basic needs have been answered because
you know they don't feel like this is
their project or they don't feel like
this is theirs and you can see it both
ways you can see it on the one hand it
can be the fault of the authority of not
being able to include these these mixed
multitudes into their project to make
them fit within their main project but
it's also it can also be seen as you
know some aspect the fault of the the
people the fault or the the reality of
the people who just don't feel like this
is their thing and so they're more prone
to continue grumbling as things manifest
themselves so this mixed multitude now
says we want meet and then God finally
gives them meat but also burns the
periphery of the of the camp right and
so let's say purges some aspect of this
problem right kind of says clamps down
says okay I'm gonna give this you I'm
gonna clamp down a little bit but now
this has to this has to stop and so
what's important in Scripture everything
is balanced out and so that can be a
really scary story it can be a very
scary story because you have this mixed
multitude you have the hierarchy and
then you have the the purge on the edge
of the
so if you were paying attention to the
video until now you will have noticed
that there was some noise in the
background that my cat was complaining
in complaining and it came to a point
where the cat was complaining so much
that I couldn't continue this video and
I actually had to stop in order to deal
with the complaint of the cat and so you
can understand this as a symbolism
happens moment because the grumbling of
the animal aspect of our family was
becoming so strong that I actually had
to interrupt the logos and interrupt the
process in order to take care and if you
pay attention in the next few seconds
you will notice that because the cat is
actually my daughter's responsibility
myself as an authority what I will do is
I will get up and I will go tell my
daughter that she needs to take care of
that which is her responsibility and
there is of course it's not explicit but
there is of course a a underlying
suggestion in my statement that I take
care of your needs I'm your father I
take care of your needs and therefore
you need to take care of your
responsibilities of which the cat is
part of and so this is precisely the
hierarchy that I'm talking about in this
video I was going to edit it all out but
I decided that because it was such a
meta moment I needed to leave it in so
let's continue on
so we have to be really careful when we
look at this the Bible because the Bible
is always very balanced it can be a bit
scary to see the story at first because
you have this idea of the mixed
multitude then you have the grumbling
and finally you have this fire which
comes and purges the outskirts of the of
the camp and so it can be a bit it can
be a bit scary but if you look at
Scripture it always balance itself out
because the next chapter right away in
the next chapter you have the flip side
of the same story so long though in the
first story you have the danger of the
danger of mixture and how we can lead to
excessive grumbling and then on the
other side you have the opposite which
is that the leaders grumble against
Moses that he is married to a foreign
woman and so they grumble about that and
because of that there's also another
punishment where Miriam who rumbles
about that is excluded from the camp for
a certain amount of time because of this
rumbling and so you can see the the
balance which is that we don't want we
don't want mixture to weigh down
that which brings us together but we
also don't want an excess of purity
which will prevent us from having this
kind of normal breathing of in and out
that all identities need in order to
exist and so just like all symbolic
patterns there is this sense in which
the notion of the grumbling of the lower
parts is an inevitable process it's an
inevitable reality of any structure
because the the higher aspects have to
take care of the lower aspects and
there's also a sense in which that can
go too far and that can also lead to the
breakdown of the system the other
breakdown can also that I hinted at
before is the breakdown of course that
if the authority doesn't end to the poor
if the authority doesn't end to those
who
our need and our grumbling then the
system can break down as well so the
system sadly can break down
well not sadly the system can break down
by all excesses either in excess of
authority or in excess of the the bottom
which is asking for too much
or is a or is never satisfied and so we
need to find a balance between the two
and that can be very difficult to find
especially as tensions escalate and
especially as discourse escalates sadly
also it is gonna be my last my little
political insert sadly in the world of
social media in the world where
everybody feels like they have to give
their opinion and somehow take a stand
on on one side or another it forces
people to move into excessive territory
because it's difficult once you create
two opposite sides it's difficult to see
the nuance even to see the nuance within
the protest where like I said there are
you within a protest there are protests
as much for a specific thing which seems
to be unfair as there is for those who
want to demolish the very idea of
Authority or the V right are the very
idea of a state and so but once your
asset takes sides
it's very dangerous because you you feel
like you have to either justify
completely one side the side of the
protests or you have to justify
completely the side of those who want to
clamp down and re-establish order and I
don't think that that's the best way to
go I think it's important to understand
the need for order and also understand
the the possibility at least that there
is that sometimes the grumbling can be
the sometimes the grumbling can be
justified because of because people feel
like they're not part of a system or
feel like they're they don't have access
to what the Authority is supposed to
provide us and so hopefully that will be
helpful for you to understand the
pattern and and will be paying attention
my next video will continue my lighter
streak just because I feel like we've
had so much heavy in 2020 I told you is
gonna get insane and I'm sorry to say
that it's
/ it's still going to get crazier but
hopefully I can also give you a little
bit of brush of fresh fresh air my next
video is going to be an interpretation
of video game symbolism you know just to
give you guys a little break from the
craziness so thanks for your support in
these wild and crazy times and I will
see you very soon so there are so many
things happening at the symbolic world
right now you know it's difficult to
keep track of everything that's going on
we have tried to use this strange Corona
lockdown to to increase the reach and
increase the type of things that are
happening there is of course the blog
that has started the new symbolic world
blog where many people have been writing
some amazing articles and every week
we're posting new articles on symbolism
on different subjects all kinds of
subjects that can be surprising to you
even there is also a the Facebook group
which is continuing strong with the
moderators doing a great job but there
is also now a new French channel where I
am going to be putting up French content
there is going to be less content of
course but when I do have French content
it's going to be there look into the
descriptions to find a link to that and
do not forget the clip channel which is
continuing to put up stuff you know
several videos every week taking out
some of the questions or some of the
little subjects that appear in my videos
and putting them together into clips
doing a wonderful job there so there is
also new merch coming out new images I
have a new image right now of a watch
the fools image of The Fool pulling up
the King in a card that was designed by
Owen Cyclops who you will hear very soon
in an interview so there's a lot of
exciting things going on please join in
the fun so thanks for your involvement
and your support